foreign
[Music]
and we are here at the Snapdragon Summit
and I'm joined by Cristiano the CEO of
Qualcomm now this is so exciting for me
not only a chance to see you and talk to
you but we're here at Snapdragon Summit
so how is this event for you so far well
this event has been great and uh look
this is our one of the most uh paper
events for Qualcomm that's where we
announced the latest and greatest
Snapdragon from the 8 series Snapdragon
has been and continue to be the platform
that really defines the pace of
innovation and mobile we've been working
very hard to make sure that is really
represent what's a premium smartphone
experiences and we're excited to tell
everybody about what Snapdragon hn2 can
do now obviously people can see
everything online but for the people
here what was the kind of idea behind
coming to Hawaii and getting to really
experience this in such an amazing
location it is a great place isn't it
it's so great wood very excited and I
think what we like it nobody complains I
haven't heard anybody said oh I don't
want to go to Hawaii it has a reason
Snapdragon it's been really utilized
globally and it has been the premium
mobile processor everywhere in Hawaii
seems to be an easier location for
people from the United States to come in
from people from Asia to come in or
there's uh we always have Partners from
Japan from Korea we used a very big
delegation from China hopefully they'll
be here next year and then you know add
to the fact that nobody complains about
coming to Hawaii it has been really a
premier event for mobile technology this
is where mobile Innovation happens it is
about not only what we show but our
partners can uh you know show some of
the use cases which can demonstrate and
it's an opportunity for people to stay
with us a couple days fully immersed in
Mobile technology and I think that's why
people keeps coming back and to Tech
Summit in Hawaii yeah it's so fun
because you just run into people that
you may have only met online or you've
been fans of their work in either
YouTube or journalism so it's like
everyone is here and you get to see them
all and learn about all the new tech So
speaking of new tech what are some of
the highlights that you guys have
announced this week the snap attack 8
gen 2. besides the speeds and feeds and
been you know some of the fastest mobile
processor in the industry right now one
thing that is different is how much
experiences are changing by AI one of
the fastest growing processor area in
the Snapdragon platform is AI processing
and you see now ai defining every
experience we talk about connectivity
we're talking about a 5G and Wi-Fi 7
plus Ai and what are some of the use
cases enabled by AI when we talk about
camera besides a great camera we now
talk about cognitive camera because you
have a lot of AI processing same thing
for sound when you think about lossless
sound between your device and your
earbuds also enabled by AI so one thing
that is different is how pervasive AI is
and we have some new technology I'm
going to go a little bit technical but
it's the ability to also create AI
processing you can continuously you know
do the computation for the use cases and
with that we announced something called
micro Precision AI we we announce a new
way of doing the processing using
integer4 you can have 60 percent
Improvement in performance per one which
means you can use Ai and not compromise
your battery life what's so interesting
is I feel like the AI buzzword is just
being tossed around all the time and
sometimes when people are saying it I'm
like I don't think you actually know
what you're saying like that doesn't
that does not apply so for you what do
you feel like AI actually is uh great
question with AI
um it's really the way I would Define it
is you have now the ability to do a lot
of parallel computation you have access
to data and you can do a lot of
inference from that data so one of the
things we're going to be talking about
it is how you think about AI in terms of
the specific use case for example in
connectivity when you think about your
5G connectivity or Wi-Fi connectivity
you move around you're using uh your
radios and you connected to the internet
but the device is learning about where
you are do you have a good signal at
that particular Point usually you'll you
drop a package or you or you have a
glitch can I increase the power at that
particular location so all of a sudden
you start to have seamless connectivity
because the device is learning about you
and what you're doing into that
competition you now can make a decision
and how how you apply the modem same
thing with camera the easiest way to
describe AI in the camera is you take a
picture at night the system knows that
that's a water that's the ocean and it's
blue so it should be blue and you know
we colored the picture for you so you
actually have the ability to take a
picture at night with no light as it was
daytime and countless examples but
really it's about making everything
intelligent you said something uh that I
like I think the AI word's been tossed
around a lot the AI started in the data
center in the cloud you have all this
data go to the cloud you do computation
you see things when you do a simple
Google search and the recommendations
that come for you but the real scale of
AI is going to happen in the devices
what we call the edge whether you make
your phone intelligent your car
intelligent you know your camera your
your music device and everything and I
think that's what we see probably the
largest opportunity for AI that's what
we call on-device AI it's interesting I
didn't even think about giving it more
power to be able to get better service I
honestly never thought about that so
that's actually a pretty unique use case
one of these cases that I recently saw
was I got a chance to go to Microsoft
and see how they were using AI for The
Voice isolation feature blew my mind
incredible I mean it was like we were
yelling in the background and you could
not hear anything but the person's voice
so that for me as a Creator I was like
this is game changing what I like about
that it's really resonate with this
whole conversation about experiences
it's not the technology for Sega
technology but can you know every one of
us right now we bring in a team's call
or a zoom call and all of a sudden you
have somebody you have a dog like my dog
had participated in a number of meetings
uh uh because he will start barking in
the background or keys or anything and
the ability to Simply take that away and
uh people can rest in wow this this will
change my experience and uh and I think
that's just the beginning I don't know
if you saw there other things we're
doing for example Microsoft teams which
means you have your camera and if you
move around somebody comes in you have
another person join you or you stand up
the camera will track and follow you and
that's just some of the cool things that
we can do with artificial intelligence
in those devices the eye days that one
was so shocking So for anybody that's
not sure of what I'm talking about if
you're actually looking at the webcam
you're making eye contact with a person
on the other end but most of the time
you're looking down or looking at
yourself or looking at the other people
so the eye gaze AI was one of my
favorite new features and a lot of
people are going to like that because
you're looking down or you're typing or
you're looking at the other side of the
screen and I think that can be corrected
so another kind of buzzword that I feel
like is tossed around a lot is the
metaverse what do you feel like this the
metaverse actually is right now and what
do you see that future of the metaverse
being there's so many different
metaverses right now that it's kind of
overwhelming like what is that going to
look like all right uh so Justine we're
very bullish about it because
I'll step back and talk about what
exactly the problem we're trying to
solve before I get to the metaverse it's
about the merger of physical and digital
spaces you know right now we're
connected you know everything's
connected this is their most connected
device and there is a digital twin of
everything there's a digital twin of
yourself there's digital twin of your
car this digital to win in your device
and everything in the cloud and the
ability to merge physical and digital
spaces this it's very transformative and
uh and it's going to happen and it's
going to get a very big scale now this
is going to materialize in different
ways so to specifically a question when
you think about the metaverse
some of the things we're doing with our
partner meta with the Oculus Quest Now
The Meta Quest they just announced a
quest Pro you know you can have a fully
immersive experience in VR and you can
see from a consumer standpoint that
could evolve into social how you know
the the way I describe this is if you go
to Facebook or Instagram and uh and then
people will put a picture or a video and
it's in a notification you go see it but
you know I can see an environment that
you could interact with other people
virtually and those things are going to
get better the content's going to get
better resolution is going to get better
so there is a social application there's
a gaming application fully immersive but
that's not only that the metaverse is
also going to develop uh on the
Enterprise side for example you can see
of somebody which is a technician and
somebody comes in with a car and you
want to do maintenance on the car you
can have the ability to look at the
digital twin of the car overlay that
information with augmented reality
devices and you can use that as a
tutorial or training or access to
information fast forward since we're
talking about cars to you know something
that we started to see in some cars
right now which is heads up display
think about a heads-up display evolving
and displaying in-ear windshield all the
information about Safety and Security is
very relevant for you or even where
you're going to find a parking spot or
things like that so all of those things
are are being developed and I think the
future is going to be one that we're
going to be able to blend physical and
disto and of course from virtual reality
this is going to evolve to augmented
reality where you're going to have fully
immersive glasses uh we're maybe 5 to 10
years away of having glasses that you
can wear and can do many of the things
that you do on your phone but it's easy
to see from a technologist standpoint
that it's possible something as simple
as a phone call that you can have this
conversation like you and I having when
I can see a hologram of you and vice
versa we're fully augmented immersive
augmented reality glasses and I think
we're just at the beginning of this
future it's so exciting it is a Creator
too just kind of getting my mind
thinking like what can I do for my
viewers to give them a really cool I'm
in a reality experience like like you
said like they could actually be sitting
next to their favorite Creator and
having a conversation or you know they
could be in their room and be now
they're magically transported into my
office and watching me film a video so
there's so many fun things and you know
you're talking about fixing cars like
this can also transfer into like
healthcare you know teaching people how
to you know do surgery there's so many
different implementations that oh it's
so fascinating I I think across every
end industry but also so for example how
people consume sports or concerts the
ability to be present in a concert or
you know into this into sports even
though you're watching from your home I
think that's uh there's a multitude of
opportunities and we're just at the very
early stages of building those devices
and having the ecosystem form now you
guys Qualcomm is it's such a huge
company and I think that you guys do so
much more than even I ever realized so
for everyone at home watching can you
give us kind of like a little I guess
overview of what types of things that
you guys are in because you're in so
many different things that I think
people don't even realize it we're doing
it a lot it's so fascinating all right
so I you know the way I would describe
Qualcomm Qualcomm is probably well known
for what we're doing what we have done
in the mobile space I think smartphone
is our most beloved device our
Inseparable devices mankind the largest
development platform and we are closing
to our processors you know Powers you
know close to 50 percent of all
smartphones in the world and there's a
lot of people in the world so that's
kind of the main thing we do the other
thing that we do as a company many of
the technologies that uh we use today
and started using in the history of
cellular 3G technology 4G technology 5G
Technologies all invented by Qualcomm
and we have been a company that's been
really focused on creating technology to
solve some of the most challenging
problems and one of the things that we
did when when we build our mobile
business is we realize that the next
Computing platform needs to fit in the
palm of your hand and and that device
needed to incorporate every single
consumer electronic device what's the
best camera in the world the one that
you carry with you all the time and
that's the that's the camera on your
smartphone same thing as your music
device is your video device it's going
to be a productivity device and so forth
and with that technology that we
developed for mobile we saw an
opportunity to take the technology to
every other device and I think that's
what we do in today so we're we're the
company providing the connectivity uh to
the cloud the processing and the
artificial intelligence for those
billions of devices that we have around
us and if I provide some concrete
examples besides phones you now find
Snapdragon into Windows PCS you find
Snapdragon on tablets as a processor you
find Snapdragon sound earbuds you find
Snapdragon wear on smart watches we also
enter the automotive space there's
something called the Snapdragon digital
chassis which is you know it's funny
Justin the reason we entered that market
is because we realize that people will
go into their car they buy a little
holder they put the smartphone right
there as they're driving well why is
people doing that because there's more
information that is relevant to them
from their phones than what you can get
on the cardio said let's just go into
the course so right now we're working
with most people don't know but we
working with the globe 29 of the global
Brands virtually every brand in the
world is using with Qualcomm connect the
car the cloud the digital Cloud pit
experience and then Adas and autonomy
but we're not stopping there we're also
working with companies they're doing
devices for the metaverse virtual
reality augmented reality devices of all
the devices that exist today which is
over 40 uh all use Qualcomm technology
and processor and we have been
expending into what we call the iot
space industrial iot and you see us in
healthcare in retail in industrial and
energy in a number of other markets
we're busy but it's exciting future
ahead of us I'm exhausted just hearing
you list off all of those things but I
mean you guys are such a massive company
and you just most recently became the
CEO a few years ago go so
congratulations thank you you've had
quite the history of the Qualcomm and
now you're kind of leading them into the
next era so I'd love to hear about kind
of your past yeah look I've been born
and raised in Brazil went to engineering
school in Brazil I got jump walk in 1995
as an engineer
and became CEO June 30th 2021 and uh
it's it's been it's been I love this
company it's been a great journey I
think I had I've been fortunate enough
to participate in every transition of
Wireless I work in Wireless in the
seller industry my whole life and I've
seen I've seen that some of the
technologies that we have developed and
we fought about we can do this at
Qualcomm had really changed the world I
think that's the motivation that we have
in this company to come to work every
day we really like being in a position
that we can change the future with
technology and that's what we'll
continue to be doing so I have a lot of
younger viewers that watch my channel
and I feel like for them kind of I don't
know just seeing people in high power
they're like what do they want to be
when they were younger and that was
something that I was always curious like
did you have a career choice in mind
when you were younger like oh I always
wanted to be this that's a difficult
question to answer you know I uh I
always like math and physics and
chemistry science I like that you know
when I wanted to go to I decided what
I'm going to do when I'm going to go to
college you know I remember my dad said
to me uh Sunday you can do anything you
want as long as Medical School law
school and engineering school so then I
said all right that's easy I like math I
like uh science I'm going to go to
engineering school I did however when I
was in school I I really got very
interested in Communications and
wireless communication I saw this huge
potential of radio communications this
is the at the time that there was uh not
cell phones yet and I think the
opportunity for for radio communications
for everyone to carry a phone with them
all the time so I got interested in that
ended following career in Wireless and
here I am so do you have any advice for
any kids now kind of like looking to get
into any types of specifications I'm
very passionate about the stem education
I think there's uh there's a lot of
opportunities in technology you know we
we look at for how much technology is
around us and uh but I think the the the
future is yet to be invented and uh I
like I'm more excited than ever been
about uh some of the advancements in the
area of communications the area of
computing the area of artificial
intelligence and uh I think uh you know
stem's a great career yeah for sure and
for with 5G I feel like that is now
pushing things even further because
we're going to be able to do things so
much quicker as a Creator this is great
I can do camera to Cloud I can upload my
videos faster but what other types of
areas do you see 5G affecting one of the
least understood capabilities of 5G you
know we talk about it's uh it's very
high speed and no more congestion you
can have a gigabit of data you have very
low latency which you can play games in
the cloud and you're not going to have
any delays we talk about consuming video
now at the way the video was designed to
be consumer of its full frame rate
there's all those things associated with
speed but one of the least understood
features of 5G is the fact that you can
have on-demand Computing I'll explain
what that means you're now connected to
the cloud with a very big pipe it's a
very high speed connectivity it's very
fast response time
so think about your device whether it's
your smartphone or your PC it's now
connected with the cloud as if they were
a single device so now you have
unlimited computing power and that's why
for example with 5G you know people that
had to have a big workstation and
they're doing a lot especially for
example on the creative side you're
doing a lot of of applications require a
lot of computation they can do in a
laptop using the power on the cloud so
you basically 5G will democratize
computing power you can have access to
as much computing power as you want
using the power of the cloud and I think
that's going to be the next game
changing feature of 5G I mean speaking
of gaming that has changed the gaming
landscape because now you're playing
your video games on your phone basically
wherever you are which is incredible
because you don't need a console you
don't need your high-powered PC and I
think it's really changing the game yeah
the mobile gaming is the fastest gaming
segment right now in the finger form of
a developer standpoint you now develop a
mainstream game and put it on the cloud
and it's not just the consoles anybody
that has a phone will be able to play
that game it's a much larger market so I
think that 5G streaming of game is going
to fundamentally change the gaming
industry yeah I remember what people
used to think Mobile gaming was just
playing like little like tap games I'm
like no I'm playing Halo right now like
I don't know about you this is really so
great because me and my sister also hi
Jenna we travel a lot so like we're able
to play basically wherever we are I mean
we used to like travel with all of our
consoles back home for the holidays and
now we don't even have to do that so
it's it's so awesome so now looking
forward into the future in the next
couple of years I guess what are you
most excited about I'm uh you know just
when you say the next couple of years I
think I'm very excited about the work
we're doing in transforming PCS I think
we you and I talk about some of the use
cases that Microsoft demonstrated I
think the Next Generation Computing for
the future of work uh we're very excited
about that that's a whole New Market for
us we expect to get scale 24. the other
thing that I'm very excited about is all
of those cars that we've been working on
with technology for assisted driving
autonomy they're going to start coming
into the market in the 25 to 26 time
frame and I think the last uh thing is I
am I believe that you know phones are
going to be here for a very very long
time but in a couple years we're going
to have our companion glasses that go
alongside our phones with augmented
reality and there's so many cool things
we can do oh I can't wait I'm even
thinking even further ahead like
actually contact lenses I mean I've seen
prototypes and things like that like
that's thinking way far in the future
but the whole glasses Tech I'm super
excited about that it's going to be
really cool thank you so much for
joining me here is there anything else
that you want to tell them about
Snapdragon or anything else to add I
think just watch uh the stream of the
Snapdragon announcements I think we're
we're very proud out of a snap drawing
hn2 and hopefully you find that in the
phone uh next time you're gonna go buy a
phone awesome well thank you so much for
chat thank you happy to do that thank
you
[Music]